[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: When it
comes to performance,
sometimes it's not the
big, glaring topics
that cause the most problems.
It's the little things
that when added together,
create huge headaches
for your application.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and one
of the quintessential examples
of small things adding
up to big problems
is a feature in the
Java programming
language known as autoboxing.
See, to the Java
language, primitive types
like int, bool, and float are
great for matching their IEEE
and hardware definitions.
But this also keeps
them from being
used with generic collections
offered by the runtime.
Instead, the Java language
provides object versions
of these primitives--
like java.lang.integer--
which give you the
same functionality
as a primitive int but can be
used with generic collections.
This is where
autoboxing comes in.
Autoboxing at its core converts
from primitives to their object
counterparts on your
behalf so that you
don't have to worry about any of
those conversions in your code,
which is generally
pretty awesome.
Take this simple for
loop for example.
We can easily treat
the integer object
just like it were
[? a permivi ?] int
without any extra syntax.
But sadly, the hands-free
nature of this functionality
comes with some
performance penalties.
See, for each step of the
integer object version
of the loop, the runtime has
to create a new integer object,
push the primitive
value into it before it
can be able to be added back
to the other integer object.
Which means that any time you
do an autoboxing conversion,
a new object allocation
comes along with it.
Compare this with
the version using
primitives that doesn't require
any additional allocation
overhead.
This is really painful to watch
since these objects are larger
in size than their
primitive counterparts-- 16
bytes for the integer
object rather than four
for the primitive-- and also
require more performance
overhead in order to access the
underlying value-- basically
creating a double whammy of
issues for memory and runtime
performance.
Now, you need to be aware
that this problem doesn't just
pop up with contrived examples
like our little for loop here.
Nope.
It's present any time you
pair a generic collection
with a primitive type,
which is especially
a problem for
containers like HashMap.
Basically anytime you insert,
edit, or retrieve values
with this generic
container while a primitive
is involved, you end up a
boxing and unboxing values,
which is the exact reason that
the Android platform provides
custom containers for you to
use in these situations instead
of HashMap.
The sparse map
family of containers
are all designed specifically to
combat the autoboxing problem,
eliminating both
the runtime overhead
and reducing the
memory footprint.
Now I if you're not
sure where in your code
autoboxing could be
causing a problem,
the ANDROStudio tools can
help you track it down.
If you're using
allocation tracker,
keep a lookout for
any places where
you have a load
of integer objects
all coming from a
single call site.
And in TraceView,
watch out for a flood
of integer.value of calls
happening for any given reason.
Both of these reports
are a clear sign
that autoboxing is occurring.
While the low hanging
fruit of performance
is the easiest to fix and
the most common to find,
these little
problems really start
to add up and cause
really big issues
if left unchecked, which is
why you need to check out
the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content
to see what else is
working in the shadows.
And of course, don't forget
to join our Google+ community
as well for other
great tips and advice.
So, keep calm,
profile your code,
and always remember--
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]